I love learning but I'm also really
timeful so I've gotten a bunch of
experts to try and explain to me
something about their field in the time
it takes for an elevator to go from the
bottom of the buildings up to the top
and then all the way back down and this
time I'm going to ask someone about
string theory now I have my own string
theory which is along the lines of how
long is a piece of it but I've heard
that string theory is actually the
theory of everything and I don't know
how you can fit that into an elevator
ride but that sounds like a ZEM problem
not a me problem so let's go see whether
they get tied up in knots
[Music]
so have you heard the saying if you
can't explain something to a
six-year-old that means you don't
understand it yourself
yes I hear that's it I'm your
six-year-old let's do this
ready
what is string theory so string theory
is the idea that at the smallest level
all of the stuff in the universe
everything we can see all the atoms etc
are made of these tiny vibrating strings
okay so why is this important it's
important because physicists are lazy at
the moment we have two fundamental
theories quantum mechanics on one hand
and we have general relative in the
other hand which describes gravity they
don't work together string theory is
this idea one of the ideas bring these
two together so we'd have one theory to
work with so do we know if string theory
is true is there evidence there's no
observational experimental evidence at
the moment problem is is that we need to
build a Large Hadron Collider the size
of our galaxy just actually test the
energies it's a theoretical idea
people love the theory of love the
mathematics but why do they love the
maths because the maths is beautiful yes
so physicists love beautiful mats and
string theory is built on this very
beautiful idea that's we're halfway are
you halfway halfway through flow let's
go back down and I want to know what
makes maths beautiful well physicists
are attracted to beautiful ideas and
beautiful mathematics mathematics you
can write down relatively simply it has
lots of consequences so you can explain
lots of things with it so string theory
is grown building up these mathematical
ideas to sort of encompass gravity and
everything else so it ties everything
together absolutely and that's why they
made it strings right aha yeah what is a
string so you know it's a tricky
question in our mathematics the strings
are these one-dimensional loops that
vibrates and how they vibrate tells you
what they are as an electron or quark or
something else oh they're all the same
but they're vibrations is what makes
yes right and they vibrated in multiple
dimensions maybe twelve fifteen or
twenty four dimensions but you can't
answer the question of what is the
string itself it's not a thing it's just
a fundamental piece of the universe it's
just a nothing that vibrates so nothing
that vibrates what makes up everything
so I'm made up of vibrating strings that
are made up of nothing vibrating strings
in nothingness nothingness absolutely
great I'm gonna go have an existential
crisis now thank you
bye wait what do you mean in nothingness
so to recap string theory is a theory
that if we could prove it could link
together a bunch of other theories about
the way that the world works it's not
the only theory that exists but it is a
really interesting one and it says that
the most fundamental thing that makes up
the universe is basically a string that
exists in one dimension yet vibrates in
multiple dimensions how I don't know and
the vibrations tell us what that string
is creating so everything in the world
is made up of these vibrating loops and
if we can learn to understand them
better then we could probably influence
them right and we could make
technologies and apparently influence
gravity and maybe even time in ways that
my mind cannot even fathom at this point
strengths
[Music]
well that ties that up with a nice
little bow of string theory string the
expert in that video gurans also has a
video about the end of the universe that
you can see in the link in the
description below it's a little bit
longer than an elevator ride but I
highly recommend it just make a cup of
tea before you go watch it if you want
to see more videos from us then you can
hit that subscribe button to get an
alert when something is ready you can
expect something from us next week as
well and if there's some big idea that
you want explained in a claustrophobic
space then put that in the comments
below and I'll see if I can find an
expert who can explain it to me so that
I can explain it to you see you next
time
[Music]